Hello and welcome to this lesson on multi-threaded programming.
This lesson begins with a brief review of parallel
programming in general and moves on to discuss multi-threaded
programming in particular. It uses the POSIX threads library as
the conical example, though the same principles apply to
most all threads libraries. To motivate parallel programming, consider
the following task. You're given a set of webpages,
some of which link to each other. We'll draw this
using a standard abstraction of a directed graph, where outgoing
edges represent links. So webpage A here contains a link
to webpage B. And our goal is to figure out,
how many links our website, say U, has pointing to it.
This is something that a search engine might do to
help figure out how popular a website is. Now, there's no
way to know whether another web page has a link
to our web page in it without looking at it. So,
in one way or another, we're going to need to read
all of the web pages in our collection. And if we
try to do this with a single processor, this could
take a long time. First, I have to read webpage A
then webpage B, etc. Thankfully, this task is highly paralyzable.
That is, there is nothing about my processing of A ie,
counting how many links it has to website U that
affects how I'm going to process website B or website C. So,
I can easily divide up the web pages among, say, three
CPUs. Let's get these over here to CPU one, these to CPU
two, and these to CPU 3. Now, we can let each CUP
count up, in its sub group, how many links it has to
you, and then we can just add these units up to
get our final answer. Returning to our time graph, we see that
with three CPUs, we only need 1 3rd of the time, potentially,
with n CPUs we would only need 1 nth of the time.
It's important to realize that we're doing the same
amount of work here. Suppose that in our original thread,
we first process the website assigned to CPU one, then
those assigned to CPU two, and then those assigned to
CPU three. Well, in parallel programming, we've cut this one
long strand of computation into three shorter strands and arranged
them in parallel by giving them to three seperate CPUs.
This, of course, is the ideal case for parallel programming.
Now of course, in real life, we don't always
get as many processors as we want, they aren't
always available. And given that our application will likely
be running on the same machine as others, we
don't know exactly how many processors we will have
access to. But by expressing our algorithim in this
way, we can take advantage of the processors that
we do have and thus make our algorithms run faster.